There are a wide range of places where
putting chemical design has taken place.
This is just a small sampling and I'll
try to talk through just a few of them
before we, uh, as we wrap up.
This is called [inaudible]. It's an, uh,
an antique pilot.
It's a marine pesticide.
There used to be a company
based in Philadelphia called
the Roman Hoss companies
has been bought out by Dow.
Okay.
So an antique pilot is something
that you put on the bottom of a boat.
You can also use it for
other things such as, uh,
cooling pipes,
etc. Etc.
But basically you want to get rid of
things like algae or seaweed or barnacles
and diatoms the cost of
scraping the ship. Uh, if, uh,
if those things accumulate, the cost of
it being out of service just builds up.
Um, and so the idea of
needing a antique tolerances,
it is important.
So whether it's the amount
of fuels that you use,
the greenhouse gases,
um,
all of those associated
with the use of those fuels,
it all adds up.
Uh,
the way that the violence are
applied is you blended with the,
the ship paint and then the, uh, the,
the file once I suppose to kill
the barnacles or the seaweed,
um,
as they try to attach and slowly
leach to the surface in order to,
um,
to,
to form the layer or
resilient or resistant layer.
This has been the dominant
Antifa island for many,
many, many decades. Uh,
try butyl tin oxide, um,
kind of like a spider.
So it's half life in
seawater is both six months.
So just the bio concentration
factor is 10 to the fourth. Now,
the chronic toxicity is a
concern, whether it's, um,
what it does to a seawall,
whelks oyster shells,
a snails, higher mammals
such as dolphins and whales.
Uh, there has been concern
known for quite some time.
It was banned by Japan, I'm guessing,
because they care for the whales. Um,
and by the, uh, International
Maritime Organization, uh,
and an o three.
So what would you want to have her,
an ideal, uh, antifouling I
want it to degrade rapidly.
Nonhazardous and environmental
conditions limited by available, uh,
availability toxical into target on an
organism's minimum bio concentration.
Right? So this is what was
invented by a Roman hat.
Um,
and this one,
the Presidential Green Chemistry
Challenge award a number of years ago. Um,
so this is the four or five tie Klara,
um,
to an octal actual fires alone alone,
we'll call it Tcli. Okay. The
good news about this is it,
um, while it is, and this
is an important distinction,
it is acutely lethal to those
things that it wants to kill.
So the reason that I chose this example
is because there are times when your
function is to eliminate LG seaweed,
barnacles, et Cetera, et cetera.
Um, so this actually
is acutely lethal, uh,
to those target organisms.
So pesticides in general are by
definition a lethal to is humbling,
but it has no chronic toxicity.
Um,
very small halflife halflife
is less than an hour.
A bio concentration rather
than 10,000 is a 13,
by comparison and
partitioning to this sediment,
which means low bioavailability.
And this is just the
breakdown process of the, uh,
the Coi and dramatically
different toxicity profile.
Um,
the,
the difference between the predicted
environmental concentrations in the no
effect concentration.